dans cette vidéo on va prouver les trois
théorème anti démocratique dont on a
parlé lundi dernier donc si je ne
l'avais pas vu cette vidéo je vous
conseille d'aller la voir faut que cet
épisode hardcore on va voir les
formalisation des théorèmes
antidémocratiques mais elle sera du coup
plus difficile à comprendre
l'épreuve est donné aujourd'hui sont
celles de john duncan jones diana coplo
ce qui ne sont donc pas à l'épreuve
originale de guy bach de 7h fouet hérité
arrow faut noter que l'épreuve de dong a
neigé à un couple hausse
elles datent des années 90 c'est ce qui
montre l'intérêt de retrouver des
théorèmes déjà approuvé mais de façon
plus simple et plus inside foule qui
nous permettent de mieux comprendre ce
qui se passe et le fait que la recherche
est actuellement très active dans ce
genre de domaine
ok donc on va commencer par le théorème
d'art aussi voulu sauter directement au
théorème de guy bach de garde cette info
était joué un lien dans la description
pour sauter le théorème d'arreau je vous
rappelle sa formation il dit que si la
seule façon d'agréger des préférences
individuelles ont une préférence de
groupes en respectant les critères
d'unanimité et d'indépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes et la
dictature à savoir les préférences du
groupe seront les préférences d'un
individu du groupe donc voici de
formaliser un petit peu buzz pour tous a
donc pour former et tout ça on va
construire un ensemble grand x
d'alternative des alternatives ça peut
être des candidats à la présidentielle
mais ça peut aussi être des lois ou je
sais pas trop quoi un peu tout et
n'importe quoi l'idée c'est qu'il faut
agréger on a plain d'individus avec des
préférences divers et variés il faut
agréger leur préférence pour ici avoir
une présence qui décrit tout le groupe
j'ai noté haine entre crochets
l'ensemble des électeurs n entre
crochets ces notations très pratique en
informatique qui correspond à l'ensemble
des antilles entre et n
et d'ailleurs je ne me restreindre cas
où x contient seulement trois
alternatives dont clic c'est égal à
l'ensemble a b et c
souvent en théorie des systèmes de vote
or ce cas que deux alternatives c'est
très facile suivi de faire un référendum
mais dès qu'on passe à trois
alternatives c'est un petit peu la merde
ça devient très compliqué très vite
c'est un de ces cas où trois est
beaucoup plus grand que d'eux même pour
des grandes valeurs de 2 alors
formellement maintenant il faut qu'on
parle de préférence des préférences d'un
individu c'est quoi ça va être une
relation d'ordre sur l'ensemble mixte
des alternatives donc une préférence
d'un individu et a par exemple j'ai noté
au l'ensemble des relations d'ordre sur
ericsson france ont des préférences
aussi notre façon de parler de ça c'est
une préférence l'état ça va être de la
forme après faire b à c donc il ya six
possibilités on peut avoir tes états
préfèrent béasse et je vous laisse
deviner quelles sont
les autres préférences possible d'un
individu plus généralement s'il y avait
un nombre x d'alternative alors le
nombre de préférence nombre de relations
d'ordre sa égal à x factor elle ça
correspond à l'ensemble des permutations
des alternatives enfin pour parler du
terme d'art où il nous reste un dernier
adieu à définir qui est l'agrégation des
préférences individuelles en une
préférence de groupe autrement dit ça
correspond à une fonction f qui va de
aux puissances n 2 qui prend un profil
de préférence bien d'état qui est égal à
tête-à-tête à 2 jusqu'à tn et qui
ressort une relation d'ordre pour le
groupe une préférence du groupe qu on va
noter f2 t'aidera cool on peut
maintenant définir rigoureusement les
mots qui apparaissent dans le théorème
d'arreau donc l'unanimité c'est quoi on
va dire qu'une fonction f est unanime si
lorsque tout le monde préfère une
alternative
xn alternatif y alors f2 tu es tu as dit
que x est meilleur qu il y aussi donc
plus formellement si pour tous types et
tailles dit que xml requête grecque
alors être de thé tadic
xm york y est on va dire que f est
indépendante aux a été un tir non
pertinente si la manière dont est dotée
ta classe x et y ne dépend que de la
manière dont les états y classe x y
une façon de formaliser sa servir à dire
que si on a deux profils de préférence
d'état et hauts qui sont d'accord pour
toutes les préférences entre x et y
donc si à chaque fois que tu es tu as i
classe x devant y alors tôt yves a aussi
classé x et y
et vice et versa si on hâte et à eto'o
qui s'accordent de cette manière alors
f2 état et l auto doit aussi s'accorder
sur le classement entre x et y
on peut maintenant revenir au théorème
d'arreau donc le terme de la rue nous
dit que si f est à la fois unanimes et
indépendantes aux élèves non pertinentes
alors est fait forcément la dictature
ce qui veut dire qu'il existe un
dictateur un qu'appartenant à haisnes
tels que la préférence du groupe l de
l'état est en fait égal à la
référence de l'individu qu'at&t taquin
les préférences du groupe sont donc les
préférences d'un individu du groupe ok
donc on va prouver sa est la preuve
c'est décompose en quatre parties en
premier lieu on va définir les individus
pivot montrer qu'ils existent et dépend
de quelques propriétés de base sur les
individus pivot ensuite on va voir que
l'individu pivot p2b slash a est en fait
dictateur pour la relation entre b et c
on verra aussi que l'individu pivot de
baisse' lâché précède forcément
l'individu pivot de ces cela hp et par
des arguments de symétrie on pourra
conclure en disant que tous ces
individus qui joue en fait c'est un seul
individu et que cet individu est
dictateur commençons doucement
commençons par définir les individus
pivot a pour cela on va partir d'un
profil de préférence où tout le monde
préfère à ab est ce qu'on va faire c'est
inversé individu par individu
la relation entre a et b donc on va
partir du premier cas où tout le monde
préfère à ab qu'on va appeler tête à 0
et donc on va oublier ses seins pour
l'instant et chaque itération on va
inverser en partant de la gauche
les préférences entre a et b donc au
début par l'unanimité on sait que comme
tout le monde préfère à ab f de teta
dois dire que tout est à 0 pour le coup
doit forcément classé à devant p mais au
fur et à mesure que l'on inverse les a
et les b on arrive finalement une
position état n à la fin où tout le
monde préfère bea a du coup f de ttn
forcément de dire que ben est meilleur
que a
et ça ça veut dire qu'il ya un moment où
cours de cette de ce processus ou la
préférence de f&a s'est inversée pour la
première fois et on va appeler p2b slash
à cet individu ou qui a causé la
première version de préférence du groupe
donc cet individu p2b sacha c'est ce
qu'on m'a appelé
du pivot et bien voir qui ne dépendent
que de b2 un peu importe les classements
de ses parrains dépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes
on sait que p2b sache à deux doigts
dépendre que que de baidoa hawks et p2b
sacha est vraiment une fonction de b21
uniquement de la même manière on peut
définir p2a ce lhc p2c slash ap2b ce lhc
p2c et slash b et p2 à slash b bien voir
que l'individu p2b slash à il est tel
que si tous les individus à sa gauche
préfère baa1 et tous les individus à sa
droite préfère ab alors la relation la
préférence du groupe entre b et a va
être déterminé par la préférence de
l'individu paie vos p2b slash a entre b
et a donc note p2b slash à parce que
tout individu la gauche préfère b et
tous les individus à droite préfère à
entremont arrivée par opposition p2a
slash baisser lorsque tous les individus
à gauche préfère à et tout individu à
droite préfère b ok donc on a défini les
individus pivot on peut passer la
deuxième partie de la preuve qui
consiste à montrer que l'individu pivot
p2b slash a en fait dicte la préférence
du groupe entre b et c est quand même
vachement surprendre pour ça on va se
replacer dans le cas où tous les
individus à gauche préfère béa et tous
les individus à droite préfère à ab et
on va mettre c'est au milieu entre béa
pour les individus de gauche est tout en
bas pour les individus de droite et on
va supposer que pour l'individu pivot
individus pivot il a une préférence
abaissé par définition de l'individu
pivot p2b l'achat ou c'est que la
préférence du groupe entre a et b va
être celle de l'individu pivot par des
fissures des individus pivot comme tous
les gens à sa gauche préfère b à a et
tous les individus à sa droite préfère
ab alors la préférence du groupe entre a
et b va être celle de l'individu prix
pivot comme l'individu pivot préférera
avait la préférence du groupe va dire f
de têtards le point après faire b par
ailleurs on peut voir que dans ce profil
de préférence b est unanimement préféré
assez
par unanimité on sait que l dette et a
dit que b est meilleur que c est donc
maintenant par transitivité 6f de tt a
dit que les meilleurs que b et que ben
est meilleur que c'est on sait que avait
été fait à ce sera forcément à préfère
béasse exposants maintenant que
l'individu pivot inverse sa préférence
entre a et b par définition de
l'individu pivot p2b sasha encore une
fois les individus à gauche préfère
berra et à droite préféreraient ap on
sait que pour ce profit de préférence
tête à prix on a f de tête un prime qui
dit que b est meilleur que a
sauf que lorsqu'on est passé de
tête-à-tête à prime on n'a pas du tout
changé les préférences des individus
entre a et c du coup le préférence du
groupe entre à etc doivent être les
mêmes pour l'état et pour ta prime
or on a vu qu'avec deux états a préféré
à assez utilisé de combativité du coup
forcément pas indépendante et non
pertinente f2 teta prime doit préférer a
assez du coup le groupe doit avoir une
préférence f2 et aux primes qui dit que
b est meilleure qu'à meilleur que c est
ce qui est vraiment bizarre c'est qu'on
a conclu que f2 teta prime d'x b est
meilleur que c'est en utilisant
uniquement le fait qu' il dise que ben
est meilleur que michael est meilleur
que c'est en fait pourvu que les
individus de gauche mais tu as an
dernier et que les individus de droite
mettra en premier et pourvu que
l'individu pivot p2b slash a préfère bea
a assez on aura forcément f2 teta prime
le classement du groupe qui dit que b
est meilleur que a
et qui dit que a est meilleur que seydou
l'on déduit que b est meilleur que c'est
selon le groupe la relation f2 teta
prime qui dit que baigneurs que c'est a
donc été dicté par l'individu pivot en
particules on peut maintenant
complètement changé les préférences
entre vais essayer d individus à gauche
et à droite on peut même mettre ses
meilleurs que ben est partout
pourvu que l'individu pivot vote b à c
c'est lui qui dicte la relation entre b
et c est ça ça commence à être super
bizarre on y est presque
considérons maintenant le cas où tous
les individus à gauche préfère c à b à a
on a supposé que l'individu pivot p2b
sache
après faire aussi cba et on va supposer
que tous les individus à droite préfère
a assez ab par unanimité on voit que
tout le monde préfère c à d maintenant
on va faire comme pour la première
partie de cette démonstration on va
inverser les préférences entre cb en
partant de la gauche et pour l'individu
pivot faire un break un peu différent on
va transformer sa préférence cba en b à
c sauf que l'on se retrouve exactement
dans le cas de la deuxième partie de la
démonstration dont on vient de parler
tous les gens à gauche préfère mettra en
premier tout les gens à droite m un o
dernier et la préférence de l'individu
pivot p2b slash a et b à c donc si on
appelle notre suite d'inversion tête à 0
t 30 est à 2 jusqu'à ttn comme on l'a
fait en partie on voit que t'es tu as
deux p2b slash a donc l'inversion du par
l'individu pivot b sacha va forcément
être une relation b préfère a assez et
en particulier la relation entre b et c
selon le groupe a déjà été inversés donc
le moment où deux premières versions qui
correspond à l'individu pivot p2b ce lhc
est forcément arrivé avant p2b slash a
autrement dit on à l'inégalité p2b slash
est inférieur ap de baisse' l'achat de
la même façon on va partir du cas où
plus un individu de gauche préfèrent b
acea à l'individu pivot préfère bea a
assez et les individus de droite
préfèrent a à b à c donc ça on va
appeler ça taux zéro puisque on va faire
ça les convois inverser les préférences
entre b et c en partant de la gauche
on part une unanimité on pourra savoir
que l de taux zéro dit que b et
meilleure que c'est moi en fait cette
relation elle est même encore vrai juste
avant que l'individu pivot switch sa
préférence entre b et c d'après la
deuxième partie puisqu'on peut en aucun
cas où tout individu à gauche mettent à
en bas et tout individu à droite mettra
en eau et où l'individu pivot préfère b
à c
on va alors transformer ses préférences
en cba inverse baissé notamment
et puis on va continuer à switcher entre
b et c donc lorsqu'on arrivait vu ce que
vous par unanimité on saura donc le f2
tôt elle préfère forcément c à b du coup
le premier switch entre c -b aura
forcément lieu quelque part après
l'individu pivot et ça ça revient à dire
que p2c slash b est forcément à droite
de p2b slash à et du coup si on combine
les inégalités qu'on a vu on a forcément
p2b ce lhc l'inférieur égale ap2b slash
à inférieur ou égal à p2c cela hp on
touche quasiment au but pouvoir que dans
toute la preuve comme on a vu jusque là
les rôles de a et b et c sont
parfaitement symétrique du coup on peut
obtenir le même genre d'inégalités si on
remplace si on fait une permutation des
as de b2c particulier je vous propose de
remplacer à part a donc ça va changer
et puis vous propose d'inverser les
valeurs de b2c de l'emi qualité
ci-dessus ou non déduit alors
l'inégalité p2 cchb inférieures ou
égales
ap de csh up affaire régale ap2b ce lhc
en particulier si on regarde le nom
deuxième égalité ou occupé de bsh c est
à la fois inférieur égale ap2b sachet
est supérieur égal du coup on a une
égalité forcément entre p2b chc et p2b
et p2c slash b et ça c'est un pic que du
coup p2b slash a&p de ces slash à sont
aussi ego et du coup on en déduit qu'en
fait tu paies de as hb et elia la p2b
cela chouette et yala p2pistes hc et à
la paix de ses smashs paix est égale
dégâts la paix de hhc est égal à p2c
slash à bref tous les individus pivot
soins fait un seul individu
or on a vu que cet individu pouvait
dicter du sud par exemple de baisser
l'âge c'est quelles que soient les votes
des autres même si les autres voter
c'est slash b mais de même par symétrie
des différentes alternatives voit qu'il
dit aussi et les préférences entre ces
slash b
as hpb sacha et tout ça bref c'est un
individu pivot des dictateurs
passons maintenant au théorème de guy
bardin
une tonne de guy badeaux libérateur
freight fait les termes de guy bardin
pic le théorème de guy bras de sa soeur
fouille du coup vous propose de prouver
le tehran de guy bras et on en déduira
du coup le théorème de guy braza turf
weight avant de donner les preuves
on va formaliser ces deux théorème donc
le théorème de guy bach de cider freight
il nous dit que le seul scrutin
déterministe qui soit unanime et sans
dilemme du vote utile est la dictature
donc un vote pour un scrutin ça va être
quoi ça va être une fonction qui un
profil de préférences individuelles
associe une alternative en particulier
on voit que ça ça exclut les vote à la
proportionnelle où c'est de représenter
un peuple
mais le vote a pas personnel ne permet
pas de prendre une décision qui
s'appliquerait à tout le monde c'est pas
c'est pas une élection d'une alternative
parmi plusieurs autres proportionnelle
ce formalisme et exclut également tous
les scrutins qui n'utilisent pas des
votes par classement donc par exemple
les votes par notation ou par jugement
qu'on verra dans l'épisode 4 sur la
démocratie ce ne sont pas prises en
compte par le formalisme du théorème de
guy badeaux hommes de guy beart
satterthwaite l'unanimité sera bien dire
que si tout le monde pense que a est la
meilleure alternative alors v doit élire
à 3 ans dix pour un profil de préférence
teta pour lequel pour tout y avait la
meilleure alternative surmonter taille
alors v de tva doit être égale à
l'absence des dilemmes de vote utile lui
un petit peu plus compliqué à formuler
se dit que si je prends n'importe quel
profil de préférence d'état si je
considère n'importe quel individu y
importe quel électeur y est question
c'est de savoir est ce que les lecteurs
il peut avoir intérêt à voter un
classement des candidats a dit plutôt
que c'est vrai préférence détail et cela
ne sera pas le cas il y aura une absence
de dilemme du vote utile
6 quel que soit le profil de préférence
d'état et quel que soit le vote que le
collecteur qui pourrait
vouloir tenter de jouer selon les
lecteurs
y on aura malgré tout v2 état qui sera
meilleur que v de hays était à moins six
ou sept nous fassions et correspond à
dire que les lecteurs et even haïm mais
les autres électeurs votent selon le
profil de préférence cet état alors pour
éviter d'avoir à dire absence de vote
fictifs qui fait beaucoup de six hubs
je vais appeler salle incentive
combativité qui est un peu la
terminologie classique en théorie des
systèmes de vote parle aussi parfois de
ce top 10 pouces naisse enfin un scrutin
dictatorial c'est quoi c'est un scrutin
tel qu'il existe un cas tels que v de
l'état peut être l'alternative préféré
par les lecteurs qu'à 30 iv de tt a va
être la meilleure alternative suivante
et ak du coup le théorème de gebhart
sather feuilles qui dit que si v est à
la fois unanimes et incentive
compatibles alors v et dictatorial le
théorème de garde lui est beaucoup plus
compliqué il est bien plus sophistiqué
et en fait lundi vous en ai donné une
version vachement ultra simplifié c'est
bien plus générale que ça donc c'est un
cas particulier qu'on a vu lundi le
théorème que guy bach d'approuver en
1977 caractérise en fait tous les
scrutins et incentive comme petit bol
est en fait il me dit qu'un scrutin et
incentive quand petit bol si et
seulement si c'est une combinaison
complexe de scrutin dit unilatéraux ou
du pl et qui sont aussi une satire
compatibles alors scrutin unilatéral
c'est un scrutin et qui est déterminé
par un seul électeur bien de scrutin
unilatéral a priori n'élit pas forcément
le préféré du dictateur il pourra par
exemple y lire le préféré avec profiter
deux tiers et le deuxième préféré avec
près d un tiers à ce moment là le
dictateur aurait quand même intérêt à
proposer
c'est vrai préférence mais bien sûr dans
ce cas on perd l'unanimité si tout le
monde est d'accord pour l'ira il ya une
probabilité non nul pour élire quelqu'un
qui n'est pas le préféré de tous
plus généralement pour qu'un scrutin
unilatéral soit une ceinture empathie
bol il faut que la probabilité d'élire
le gippus ligne m préféré d'indy
la terre est toujours inférieur ou égal
à la probabilité est d'élire le jm
préféré du dictateur par ailleurs un du
pl ça va être un scrutin qui ignorent
toutes les alternatives par deux et qui
fait une espèce de référendum entre les
deux alternatives restantes
mais le vainqueur du référendum et pas
forcément déterministe et pas forcément
l'alternative majoritaire on pourrait
mettre tes alternatif sur différents
pied d'égalité et par exemple avoir un
statu quo est une alternative a voté aux
deux tiers par exemple ça ça serait un
dupes incentive compatibles alors la
preuve du théorème de guy barde et super
technique super difficile et un trop
difficile pour un épisode de leur corps
ceci étant dit je vais quand même prouvé
une version qui est un peu plus générale
que la version que j'ai donnée lundi
je vais prouver une version où certains
électeurs peuvent avoir un plus grand
droit de vote que d'autres secteurs
comme c'est le cas par exemple dans un
conseil d'administration le drame quand
on va prouver le suivant le seul scrutin
aléatoire unanime et incentive
compatible est la dictature aléatoire
chaque électeur mais dans l'urne un
nombre de bulletins qui est égal à son
droit de vote
donc les îles on peut avoir différents
droits de vote du coup et alternatives
et lui va être élu en tirant au hasard
un butin de lure à rien détails que j'ai
laissé sous silence
lundi dernier je veux pas trop insister
dessus non plus aujourd'hui c'est que
pour que le théorème de guy bach de soit
valable il faut supposer que les
préférences sont des préférences dit
bono man morgenstern je suis pas rentrer
dans les détails de ce que sont ses
préférences même si ça en fait très
important et aux thermes ans j'ai
personnellement trouvé des théorèmes qui
ont l'air d'être incompatible avec le
théorème de guy bardin mais qui en fait
le sont pas parce que il ya cette
hypothèse sous jacente tant en termes de
gibbs qui sont que les préférences sont
bonnes mais morgenstern
donc c'est un détail qui est important
mais pas pouvoir assister de sud est
assez longue
telle quelle elle posséderait en fait il
reste super dur à prouver et pour
aujourd'hui on va n'en voir qu'une
esquisse de preuves
décomposée en cinquième qui a plein de
détails qu'il faut compléter pourquoi
avoir une preuve rigoureuse on considère
donc un scrutin v avec au moins trois
alternatives qui cette fois va élire une
loterie doit de probabilités sur
l'ensemble des alternatives x on va
supposer que v et incentive compatible
est unanime et on va prouver qu'il
s'agit forcément d'une dictature
aléatoire et pour ce faire on va
esquisser 5e et je vous laisse compléter
détails sur le premier lem dit que
lindsay 9 compatible iti un pic la
localité en localité c'est quoi c'est de
dire que si on a un profil de préférence
l'état et si dans ce profil
on a un électeur i qui préfèrent cas à
elle mais juste devant kyle juste devant
elle si l'individu les lecteurs y
inverse qu'a est elle donc on obtient à
ce moment là un autre profil de
préférence tête a pris alors la
probabilité de l'élection d'un candidat
j différent de careil de elle ne va pas
changer la priorité de l'élection ce que
j'ai noté v2 tt de jyske est la pro a
était d'élire j parce que le profil de
préférence était à ça cela torah est
égal arrivé de tête a pris mais j alors
pourquoi est-ce que l'initiative
compatibility impliqua localité c'est
parce que si les électeurs y pendant
adoré
l'alternative j et s'il pouvait en
inversant cas elles augmenté très
légèrement la probabilité d'élections de
j alors ils pourraient avoir intérêt à
faire cette inversion au moment du vote
donc quoi vous pouvez imaginer ce que
vous dis là c'est très intuitif c'est
pas du tout formel je vous invite à
essayer d'en écrire une preuve
rigoureuse or si on passe directement de
tête-à-tête à prime d'après le lem
précédent on sait que on affecte pas du
tout les probabilités d'élection de j
donc si maintenant on prend un profil de
préférence teta ou pour un électeur ica
et elles se suivent
alors si on inverse calais l on a un
effet de localités qui doublent donc
n'affecter que k et l
cependant a priori cet effet deux
localités s'élève à l'effet que savoir
sur l'épreuve et élection de cas et elle
lorsqu'on inverse ce cas elle pourrait
dépendre du profit de préférence de tout
le monde
le second lem dit que l'inversion de
préférence entre cas et elle va avoir un
effet qui ne dépend pas de la position
d'un d'une troisième alternative j dans
les préférences des autres individus
pour cela ce qu'on va faire si on va
considérer un autre éditeur qui prime et
on va monter j ou descendre j d'un cran
donc on va partir de teta qui est donc
le profil initial on va passer de teta a
tôt en montant régie d'un cran dans les
préférences d'un autre électeur qui
prime puis on va inverser cas elles ont
affaire l'inversion de kahel pour les
préférences et les lecteurs y donc ça ça
va me faire passer de toa taux prime
puis on va revenir à un état prime
oh non en redescendant j d'un cran dans
les préférences de hybrid est donc toute
cette suite d'opérations doit être
équivalente à passer directement de
tête-à-tête à prime abord passer de teta
a été aux primes c'est un certain effet
de localités sur l'épreuve et élection
de cas et de l est on voit que cet effet
doit être du coup le même sur les
épreuves et élection de cailhavel que
celui de cet autre flèche ici or les
seuls moments où on a fait que les
probabilités d'élection de cas et 2
elles sont sur cette fois-çi ci est sûre
cette flèche ici et du coup peu importe
la position de j au final chez les
autres électeurs l'effet de localités de
l'inversion de calais 2 elle doit être
le même donc cet effet ne dépend pas de
la position de jcs dans les préférences
des autres électeurs et le troisième lem
va déduire du lem précédent le fait que
le scrutin ne dépend en fait que des
élections préféré des électeurs or pour
cela on va supposer que j ai unanimement
préféré que les lecteurs qui préfèrent
cas juste devant elle
dans ce cas par l'unanimité du vote on
sait que j doit être élu avec
probabilité 1
mais dans ce cas ci on inverse k et l on
reste dans un cadre unanimité sur j du
coup on affecte pas la probabilité
d'élections de cas et de l
c'est forcément ce sera toujours égale à
zéro en utilisant le lem précédent on
peut descendre les gie dans les
préférences des autres individus et on
voit que l'inversion de kayes elle n'a
aucun effet le seul effet que les
lecteurs y aura sur les propriétés
d'élection des différentes alternatives
va être pas sur ces votes en bas ça va
être uniquement quelle est l'alternative
qui met en premier du coup c est
maintenant qu un scrutin qui est unanime
et incentive qu'un petit bol doit en
fait être uniquement une fonction des
alternatives préféré par les différents
électeurs mais a priori on sait pas trop
quelle va être l'effet du directeur et
de choisir
une thérapie vigie comme préféré sur les
probabilités détection des différents
candidats bien le quatrième lundi que le
fait pour un électeur hideux m j tout en
haut de sa liste de préférence va
augmenter d'une quantité epsilon y la
probabilité d'élections de j cette
probabilité epsilon hic il rajoute à son
alternative préféré va être la même quel
que soit l alternative qui met un an au
transit epsilon il ne dépend pas de j et
pour cela c'est ma façon va partir d'un
profil t de préférence teta et on va
supposer que pour telle alternative
préféré par les lecteurs y doit être
égale à une certaine alternative x1
donc je vais appeler une vue noté grant
x est égal à ixelles jusqu'à x m
l'ensemble des alternatives est ce qu'on
va faire si on va partir de deux états
on va poser tête à 1 est égal à l'état
et on va construire une suite de profils
tête-à-tête à deux têtes à 3 ci-dessus
ce disque la tête à m + 1 ou à chaque
fois on va remplacer l'alternative
préféré de l'électeur y en pas en
commençant par éric saint pie x 2 x 3
jusqu'à xm et on va revenir à la fin sur
x craint donc ça nous fait une suite de
profil et par le principe de localités à
chaque fois lorsqu'on passe de teta irak
tarit plus simple on affecte les
probabilités d'élections que de xxi et
xxi +1 et si on regarde ce qu'on fait au
bout de la boucle on voit qu'on doit
forcément revenir au point initial donc
la somme des effets de localités et doit
être nul et ça ça implique que les
variations des projets étaient
d'élections en fait tu dois tout
s'annule et à chaque fois et en
particulier l'augmentation de la
probabilité de l'éjection d'une
alternative en fonction du préféré de
lecteurs qui ne dépend pas de
l'alternative dont il est question et
ciani ne dépend pas donc de
l'alternative préféré par les lecteurs
cependant et piquionne et a priori il
pouvait encore dépendre de ce que les
autres nouveautés et bien le cinquième
et dernier l'est
on dit qu'en fait et si lon i ne dépend
pas de ce que les autres électeurs font
donc les pylônes et ne dépend vraiment
que de i
là encore l'astuce c'est de construire
une suite de préférence qui bouclent en
satin sens donc on va partir de teta ou
dante état on va se poser que les
lecteurs y préfère l'alternative ji
électeurs y prime préfère l'alternative
cas on va passer de têtards hâte aux
remplaçants car par elle puis on va
passer de toa taux prime
remplaçants j par h puis on va passer de
taux prime à tête imprime en place en
elle par cas et enfin on va on peut
revenir ou et état initial remplaçant h
paris donc ça nous fait une boucle n'est
encore on peut regarder les variations
sur les probabilités direction des
différents candidats lorsqu'on suit
cette boucle à la fin ça doit revenir
truc initial du coup cette zone en
particulier d'une relation entre le
epsilon dit ici et le ypsilon y ici
saisissant attentionné mans les valeurs
de j -h carré elle peut voir que ces
deux valeurs doit forcément s'annuler et
du coup que epsilon qui ne dépendent pas
de du candidat préféré de l'électeur qui
prime du coup un pilote qui ne dépend
que d'eux enfin on peut ré interpréter
tout ça en disant que bayonne c'est le
droit de vote des électeurs y
il contribue avec en n'augmentant d'une
probabilité et pilot dit la probabilité
d'élections de son alternative préférées
et ça ça correspond exactement à la
dictature aléatoire c'est ensuite un jeu
d'enfant de vérifier que la dictature
aléatoire et bien unanime et incentive
compatibles enfin si on exige que le
vote doit être déterministe ça veut dire
que les epsilon ils ne peuvent pas être
fractionnaire qui sont forcément une
bourrée 0,1 et du coup il ya forcément
un électeur cas pour lequel
epsilon qu'havas est égal à 1 et pour
tout le reste ça va être épique diva est
égal à zéro et les lecteurs cas sera
alors le dictateur bref vous voyez que
ces thèmes sont loin d'être évidents
mais ils nous disent comme quelque chose
de très profond sur la nature des
scrutins en général et du coût de la
prise de décision collective dont la
démocratie est un cas particulier